pero bueno muchas gracias bueno es que
al iniciar esta sesión cuando veíamos a
este vídeo del 8 de marzo no sé no sé a
ustedes pero a mí se me enchina o se me
enchinó la piel porque justamente las
luchas de las mujeres han sido
históricas y esto comienza a registrarse
hace más de 300 años en la ilustración
sin duda no vengo a hablarles de la
historia del feminismo y de las luchas
que hemos encabezado pero si vengo a
hablarles de algunas experiencias que
seguramente ustedes también han vivido a
lo largo de su vida
en el momento que platicaba un poco
sobre cómo armar esta plática que se
llama hazlo como niña recordaba que
desde niña me tuve que enfrentar muchas
veces a la palabra no
no una palabra que es muy sencilla que
tiene sólo dos letras pero que
desafortunadamente nos condiciona a
niños ya niñas porque él no está aplica
de diferente dependiendo nuestro género
a las mujeres desde niñas se nos dice no
puedes eres niña
no hagas eso bien
no es de niñas
y así
o años se nos va condicionando
pero este condicional también a los 5
años genera la confianza y la seguridad
tenemos que afianzar como niñas
si de manera cuando va
también de los 5 a los 11 años nos dicen
no te preocupes no tienes que ser
inteligente aunque seas bonita
es una princesita ayude la pobre no
puede
te ves más bonita
este tipo de duda nos violenta este tipo
de palabras nos niega como niña en
construcción a soñar en grande
a pensar que tenemos oportunidad de
triunfar de luz y de incidir
pero la bomba
en donde nos van violenta francés y de
las palabras nos encontramos con otra
triste realidad
los juguetes estereotipados
estos juguetes que tampoco nos permiten
tener una construcción de hortaleza
nos pasa aquí cositas para hacer parte
maquinitas de coser
muñequita que hay que cambiarles el
pañal y darles de comer
y la que no puede faltar el kit de
belleza
este tipo de regalos nos condiciona
porque los juguetes generan códigos y
estos códigos quedan afianzado en
nuestra mente de manera positiva o de
manera negativa
yo les propondría aquí que ahora que
justo viene la paz
pensemos muy bien el tipo de regalo que
vamos a dar a la niña
no rega
y que no sea
de cuidado pareciera que las mujeres
estamos diseñadas para cuidar desde que
somos pequeñas y esto finalmente
nuevamente nos condiciona a no entender
que podemos tener roles de liderazgo de
fuerza y de poder
y cuando esto se nos condiciona
empezamos a entender por qué los varones
son audaces y las mujeres somos débiles
porque los tres son activos y las
mujeres somos pasivas
y este tipo de construcción que se ha
dado a lo largo de mi vida seguramente
también de su vida la tenemos que
deconstruir y tenemos que desaprender
porque la verdad yo me he preguntado
muchas veces en qué momento de la vida
la palabra niña se utilizó como símbolo
de debilidad
ustedes no
alguien sabe en qué momento fue en qué
momento la palabra niña se utiliza para
denotar para minimizar y para ofender
pues yo la verdad es que soy una persona
muy curiosa y me puse a investigar
y entendí que desde 1713 puesto en
madrid se forma la primera la lengua ahí
la primera definición de femenino y de
niña era igual a debilidad
y la definición de sexo débil saben cuál
es la definición
junto de mujeres
esto significa que llevamos 305 años
utilizando de manera errónea y machista
la palabra niña
como no entender entonces que la palabra
niña también una sigamos utilizando para
denotar o para ofender
mi último que llegue
peleas como niña
luchas como niña corres como niña y si
les dieran una mímica como es pelear
como niña
no todas
en todos los espacios y en todos los
ámbitos que se nos empieza a condicionar
la verdad es que yo decidí que teníamos
que cambiar significa la piña y por eso
es que yo también estoy aquí y quiero
invitar a todos ya todas para que
construyamos esa definición de lo que
significa cambiemos la definición de la
palabra niña pongo aquí niña nunca dejes
de luchar imagina sueña actúa como una
líder hazlo como una niña porque hacerlo
como una niña es hacerlo con mucha
fuerza hacerlo con pasión hacerlo con
liderazgo es por vencidas porque sabemos
perfectamente bien que en esta vida hay
que demostrar doblemente la capacidad
porque así se nos ha condicionado
cuando yo decidí actuar y hacerlo como
niña hace ya más de 21 años decidí irme
de mi casa
cuando me fui me fui a estudiar fuera de
mexico sola
evidentemente también en esta vida me
enfrenté a muchos nos edurne no vas a
aguantar tantos años fuera de tu casa
cuatro años te vas a regresar al primero
aquí nos vemos en algunos meses
edurne cómo va a ser estudiar eso en
méxico nadie lo conoce te vas a morir
después
sin duda cuando me fui estuve sola tuve
miedo y muchas veces pensé en querer
regresar me acuerdo que afuera del
departamento donde vivía había un gran
elevador verde y tenía una fría
pues que pedías el elevador se
iluminaban todas las luces
llega a veces elevado el momento
decisivo donde yo decía ya no puedo
estoy cansada estoy sola como sola
camino sola y duermo sola me voy
pensaba justo cuando veía este elevador
en todos esos nodos que yo me había
llevado en la maleta
se me enchina la piel
y recordaba que no me tenía que dar por
vencida
así que nuevamente regresaba a mi
departamento me encerraba y recordaba
frases que en mi casa me han dicho desde
que soy pequeña
todo en esta vida está permitido menos
darse por vencidas
esta frase se la repito a mi hijo de 10
años la comparto con mis amigas la
compra con muchas mujeres y con niñas
pequeñas que he tenido la oportunidad de
pasar a partir tiempo
no
ya se levantará
no te debe ensuciar
tiene que experimentar
no edurne este no es correcto que diga
estas palabras déjala deja de expresarse
porque si desde pequeña nos dicen que no
a todo
por eso crecemos con tantos miedos y con
tantos temores y después de cuatro años
fuera de mi casa decido regresar a
mexico
cuando regreso a méxico también me
enfrente a muchos
no edurne no vas a encontrar trabajo te
lo dijimos
no edurne aquí nadie conoce lo que es la
imagen y la comunicación estratégica
edurne el mundo donde estás es el mundo
de los hombres la política es el mundo
de los hombres el liderazgo es el mundo
de los hombres
y saben que en ese momento yo decidí
cambiarlos no por los no
por qué no demostrar que siendo niña
podría triunfar que siendo mujer podría
hacer las cosas de la misma manera que
un varón podría hacerlo
por supuesto frente a muchos retos
recuerdo una anécdota muy interesante
porque claro mi nombre edurne no es un
nombre común y entonces me empezaron a
recomendar en algunos espacios diciendo
que yo hacía campañas que yo hacía cosas
de marketing y entonces de agua piscina
y cuando llego a la oficina de este
personaje político me siento llega a
hora y media tarde y cuando pasa se le
queda viendo no me dan los buenos días
se mete a la oficina
y en ese momento me dice la chava en la
recepción edurne adelante pasa te está
esperando cuando entró él estaba
volteado en su silla viendo unas cosas
en su escritorio opuesto y entonces dice
bienvenido edurne
esto es lo que siento y cuando será la
que me queda viendo asombrado y me dice
es mujer
y eres joven
sorpresa
le dije pero no sé que estaban esperando
un viejito a un perro a un gato un
changón pero aquí estoy yo porque tú me
llamaste en que te puedo ayudar
ahora decir que esta campaña se ganó
pero evidentemente la desconfianza
empezó te vieron joven y mujer porque
existe un problema de división que se
llama edad mismo mujer nos contrata
porque somos muy jóvenes
y después ya somos muy viejas
no importa
saliendo de ese despacho ya tenía yo mi
propio de espacio fundado mi despacho
seguir trabajando porque podía tocando
puertas picando piedras me caí lloré
perdí pero aún así me levanté fueron más
veces las que decidí levantarme que
quedarme tirada lamentándome y pensando
en todos esos no para darle la razón a
todos las gentes del exterior en que me
habían dicho que no iba a poder yo les
puedo decir que fui la mujer en hacer la
captura en imagen y comunicación todo el
plan de estudio sacar el revoe coordinar
y ser catedrática en muchas
universidades porque esta carrera no
existía aquí en méxico y todo por todo
aquí en puebla fui la primera mujer en
2006 comenzar a investigar a difundir y
analizar el tema del comportamiento no
verbal cuando una si esos temas
en washington dc por la vía de artes y
ciencias políticas y el año pasado es
más este año porque todos estamos en
2018 recibí el premio a la mujer más
influyente de la comunicación política
no saben cómo disfrute este triunfo
porque recordaba todos esos no que me
habían dicho desde niña yo tengo 40 años
aunque no parece pero tengo 40 y me ha
costado mucho tiempo este recorrido de
mi vida
pero así como me costó y así como me
cerraron puertas y así como me dijeron
que no podía porque era niña y así como
me dijeron que era un mundo de toby pues
les quiero decir que todos vivimos en el
mundo de tobe y lo que tenemos es dejar
de esperar que venga un príncipe azul
porque también les tengo una noticia a
mis 40 años
el príncipe azul
nosotras somos las verdaderas
protagonistas de nuestra historia no
somos las que tenemos que escribir el
guión en nuestras manos está triunfar y
demostrar que hacerlo como niña es
hacerlo de la mejor manera posible
una vez que había conseguido ya varios
espacios y había tirado muchos nudos y
muchas falsas creencias decidí que era
momento de hacer algo más por las
mujeres que venían atrás sino que venían
atrás en un tema de reconocimientos sino
en un tema de edad
porque si a mí me había costado luchar
triunfar reconocerme hacerme visible
porque en este mundo lo que hacen con
las mujeres es invisibilizar
solamente tenemos que pensar las calles
con nombres de mujeres existe cuántas
mujeres ilustres existen cuántas marcas
de identidades están construidas a
partir de mujeres
esto es invisibilizarnos y eso es
violentar nos
así que entendí que si a mí me había
costado lo que podía hacer era generar
un espacio de acompañamiento para más
mujeres
un espacio en donde las mujeres nos
viéramos y nos reconociéramos un espacio
en donde nos diéramos la mano y ahí
surge la idea de 33s hay tres el primer
objetivo tiene es que estamos ahí nos
registramos con nuestra niña interior
hay que perdonarlo hay que decirle que
estuvo bien que los hombres lo hicimos
bien que las condiciones externas
influyeron pero que eso ya pasó lo
segundo porque logramos demostrar que
las caretas de sonoridad existen porque
y difunto que las mujeres somos nuestras
peores enemigas y mientras esta
construcción social siga violentando nos
dividiendo entonces las mujeres no vamos
a alcanzar puestos de poder liderazgo y
de representación
en estos ya casi tres años de
experiencia en este proyecto de 33 hemos
recibido mil 333 vídeos de mujeres
líderes que ya inciden en sus espacios
en sus entornos en sus comunidades pero
que de alguna manera no han tenido
todavía la posibilidad de volver
exponenciales el liderazgo por falta de
capacitación de conocimiento dadas de
recursos y por eso es que en puebla nos
unimos hombres y mujeres a generar el
primer proyecto solidario y saben que me
dijeron ahí
el lunes está
en puebla no te dan ni los buenos días
los poblanos son bien especiales
pero saben que no hubo una sola puerta
que no haya tocado que me dijeran si
como te ayudo como su no
subieron medios de comunicación ponentes
conferencistas y la miel esta máxima de
estudios se volvió a aliar de este gran
proyecto
hoy llevamos más impactados de manera
indirecta a más de 1000 mujeres porque
estas mujeres en dos generaciones han
tenido que hacer su día 33 porque algo
que quiero que se lleven es que el
conocimiento si no se comparte no sirve
no podemos ser dueños de todo el
conocimiento tenemos que compartir
tenemos que dejar de competir y por eso
es que yo les propia en este espacio que
generemos este tipo de cadenas virtuosas
también ya genera generación de 33
nuevas masculinidades en donde hombres
también empatiza ni entienden que deben
de ser aliados por la igualdad genera de
monitoreo de violencia política en este
proceso histórico electoral en méxico
porque es muy liderazgos femeninos yo
estoy convencida que en este salón puede
estar la próxima diputada senadora
70 méxico una mitad solamente lo que
tenemos aquí lo que nos han autoimpuesto
la cultura por eso me gustaría que nos
fuéramos con cuatro grandes compromisos
el primer compromiso es que no
rey
no
es una lucha por nuestros derechos y el
vídeo de la poesía
no
y que se respeten nuestros derechos y 4
vamos a rodearnos de mujeres que
irradian luz mujeres que brillen mujeres
que quieran compartir porque cuando
encontramos este tipo de mujer nos
llenan y nos iluminan con su luz yo
estoy convencida que muchas de ustedes
aquí conocen a estas mujeres pero no
hemos podido acercarnos por miedo pero
no tengamos miedo porque hay allá muchas
manos muchas mujeres dispuestas a
compartir estos cuatro grandes
compromisos no nos tenemos que llevar
hoy en este salón porque yo sé que aquí
para esta selección estas futuras
líderes están los futuros líderes
y van a ser los encargados de tener en
sus manos las políticas públicas van a
tener en sus manos la capacidad de
contratar mujeres
y yo quisiera nada más decirles que de
hoy en adelante lo más controversial y
lo más nuestra vida
niñas muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]